that rumor about Kevin Costner in
Yellowstone is an absolute lie according
to the star's lawyer but what do
Costner's co-stars have to say about it
after struggling in Los Angeles in a
series of odd jobs Kevin Costner won
roles in several B movies before making
it big in the late 80s with roles in the
hit films The Untouchables Bull Durham
and Field of Dreams the actor sat in the
director's chair for 1990s Dances with
Wolves and went on to win two Academy
Awards for Best Director and best
picture as one of the Western's
producers after a few major flops he
kept a relatively low profile for a
Hollywood a-lister but in 2018 Costner
turned his skills to the small screen
with his role as family patriarch John
Dutton and Taylor Sheridan's hit drama
Yellowstone his performance is one of
the boldest and most enigmatic of his
long career with his co-stars at one
time offering praise for the veteran
performer's onset Behavior but these
compliments grew few and far between as
the fifth season of the drama unfolded
and Costner's behind the scenes actions
allegedly upset some of his fellow
performers according to a report by puck
some of the cast and crew has been quote
frustrated by costume ego and his
unavailability for a few years now and
rumor has it that Yellowstone could be
on its last legs thanks in part to a
standoff over Costner's very limited
availability according to the
publication Costner negotiated That
season five would be filmed in two parts
each with an abbreviated filming
schedule then Costner came down with
covid-19 during principal photography it
is alleged that the actor refused to
prolong his shooting schedule to make up
for the delay due to his illness
of its progress you seek
do not vote for me I am the opposite of
progress
instead Costner noted to the cast and
crew that his window for filming had
come to an end and thus forced his
fellow actors to reconvene months later
to shoot a scene scan thereby eating
into their schedules this is also the
claim made by Taylor Sheridan but
Costner disputes the allegations
entirely and claims he was only
following the terms of his contract
according to Marty singer one of
Costner's attorneys the idea that Kevin
was only willing to work one week on the
second half of season five of
Yellowstone is an absolute lie it's
ridiculous and anyone suggesting it
shouldn't be believed for one second the
behind the scenes Yellowstone filming
schedule controversy is just one element
of a greater portrait regarding
Costner's strained relationship with
Taylor Sheridan's production a report
from deadline indicated that Sheridan
was frustrated by Costner's limited
availability for Yellowstone due to his
commitment to his own upcoming Western
frontier Saga Horizon which will be
split into four separate movies
according to variety the deadline report
further alleged that Paramount was
moving to conclude Yellowstone at the
end of its Fifth Season before
developing yet another spin-off this
time with Matthew McConaughey as a lead
rather than Costner deadline lines
report paints a grim picture regarding
the future of Costner's corner of the
Yellowstone franchise though several
other reputable sources have muddied the
waters such a strategy conflicts with
what star Cole Hauser previously told
Entertainment Tonight about the
longevity of the series and suggests
that the issues surrounding Costner may
have precipitated Sheridan ending
Yellowstone early however The Hollywood
Reporter spoke to sources who indicated
that Costner departing would not mark an
immediate ending to the series meanwhile
Paramount network has suggested that
both Yellowstone and Costner's role on
the drama are set to continue a
Paramount Network spokesperson told
deadline we have no news to report Kevin
Costner is a big part of Yellowstone and
we hope that's the case for a long time
to come
[Music]
foreign